[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le coronavirus a déjà fait
un peu plus de 3000 morts dont quatre en
france sur 130 cas recensés ce matin l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
a porté le niveau de menace au degré
maximum très élevé le virus est assez
contagieux il se répand très vite mais
il semble être moins grave qu'on le
redoutait le site de l' oms recense 40
5300 guérison soit la moitié des 90
milles contamination dans le monde dont
80 milles en chine en france nous n'en
sommes pas encore au stade de l'épidémie
à proprement parler le virus ne circule
pas largement dans la population mais
nous sommes passés vendredi au deuxième
stade le stade en dessous de l'épidémie
quand apparaissent dans plusieurs
régions des grappes deux cas il s'agit
non pas de bloquer le virus ça c'était
le premier stade mais de le freiner de
le retarder
pour gagner du temps et préparer la
riposte alors pour comprendre ce que le
corps navires us deux particuliers
c'était pas la grippe ce n'est pas et
bola ce n'est pas la peste
nous avons évité ellis clément frutos
vous êtes médecins infectiologues à la
pitié salpêtrière en charge de l'unité
d'isolement charles nicolle vous êtes
l'adjointe du professeur éric comme le
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses de la pitié c'est l'une des
deux équipes qui suit le plus grand
nombre de personnes à faire infecter par
le coronavirus en france alors qu est il
de particulier ce coronavirus mais déjà
au niveau épidémiologique donc c'est un
petit peu particulier parce que ce n'est
pas le sar ce donc le virus avec plus de
10 % de mortalité qu'on a connu ce n'est
pas donc plus un coroner virus jean tic
d'un un taux le rhume comme la plupart
des coronavirus donc il a une position
intermédiaire une autre particularité
c'est sa capacité à se déplacer via les
avions puisqu'il est transporté par les
hommes qui se déplace depuis et même
d'apporter une carte et même à voir
comment ceux ci recule le coronavirus
dans le monde c'est à travers les
aéroports onda et
c'est ça qui fait qu'il peut aussi
rapidement se répandre aux quatre coins
du monde et dans tous les pays du monde
et on voit très bien qu'il suit la voie
des avions et qu'il se répand à partir
des aéroports
autre particularité c'est là
le contexte d'aujourd'hui la capacité
qu'ont à suivre au jour le jour le
nombre de cas confirmés et
d'avoir ces deux cartes et ses courbes
magnifiques qui peut être assez
anxiogène deuil absolument si on ne sait
pas par rapport à seulement tuer on nous
donne des chiffres et voilà donc
évidemment le fait que nous on est dans
une population toujours plus nombreuse
dans le monde et avec des zones de 10
paires densité de population
effectivement qui favorise sa
dissémination
et puis on parlera j'espère peut-être un
peu du contexte en france et puis de ses
effets secondaires secondaire plus
politique et non médicaux alors franck
dedieu vous êtes journaliste directeur
adjoint de la rédaction de marianne vous
êtes spécialisé dans l'économie puisque
vous avez été rédacteur en chef adjoint
de l'expansion est professeur d'économie
et de culture générale à l'ipag business
school dans le dernier numéro de
marianne d'ailleurs vous avez enquêté
sur les conséquences économiques
mondiales du cornât virus on va
l'appeler coronavirus pour faire simple
même si c'en est un particulier alors
qu'est ce que vous voyez vous de de
singulier là dedans de nouveaux
d'inédits de moderne c'est l'ampleur du
de la mondialisation qui est nouvelle
2019 on a fait des comparaisons avec le
strass 2003 et on est finalement le
système dans lequel sincères et la peur
du précédent virus il ya 17 ans et
aujourd'hui est à peu près le même du
point de vue des grands principes
en revanche en ce qui concerne l'ampleur
de la mondialisation on est dans un
autre domaine on se dit finalement 2003
c'était à peu près hier on ne découvre
pas l'importance de la chine dans la
chaîne de production dans son importance
du point de vue de la croissance
économique mondiale en fait si c'est un
autre monde
entre 2003 et et de et aujourd'hui vous
avez les importations françaises
provenant de chine qui ont augmenté de 2
180% 280% presque trois fois plus plus
de trois fois plus donc effectivement
vous vous dites dans ces conditions là
au fond nous sommes dans le même système
de mondialisation oui mais dans la
mesure où il a pris une autre ampleur
eh bien on a changé d'univers on la
change et du verre avec une capacité de
d'enrayer cette machine encore plus
forte notamment après après on en
reparlera mais tout cela s'insère dans
une sorte de
2 du bri financière de mondialisation
des changes et qui évidemment expose la
france parce qu'on a fait aussi des
choix des choix de délocalisation
exposer la france à une risque de
récession si évidemment une passe de la
france oui mais alors justement on y
reviendra mais je veux dire que quelque
part en fonction de la stratégie qu'on
eut des pays au regard de la
mondialisation
eh bien ils ont une exposition de
différentes natures l'allemagne n'a pas
le même problème quelque part au à la
chine la même relation machinima
l'experte wallingford bah oui mais voilà
où par exemple que l'italie qui a
peut-être besoin de deuil en exhortant
vive est venue vers la chine
on peut avoir des problèmes aussi
exactement ce dont on a on a des
caractéristiques de dépendance
économique à l'égard de la chine qui est
différent en fonction des stratégies
préalable de mondialisation de telle
manière on s'insère dans ce système là
tu les meilleurs vous êtes professeur de
psychologie à l'université paris-x
nanterre est spécialisé en psychologie
sociale
vous travaillez sur la perception des
risques vous collaborez d'ailleurs
régulièrement avec les agences de santé
sur les questions de communication sur
les messages de prévention
alors pour vous à vos yeux avoue de
psychologues qu'est ce qui lie à 2-2
particulier dans cette épidémie de
cornas virus je trouve qu'il s'agit de
surtout de l'amplification de dans
l'estimation des risques en effet qu on
appelle l évaluation des risques et
d'estimer sa probabilité et le risque je
sois même victime est donc en général on
a tendance à surestimer les risques
rares et là typiquement on a affaire à
une surestimation extraordinaire du
niveau de risque par rapport aux
objectifs un objectif par rapport aux
objectifs
donc ça séduit effectivement ou fait que
la surmédiatisation fait que je récupère
je vais récupérer en mémoire lorsque le
dis parce que je suis exposé moi même je
vais récupérer en mémoire toute
l'information que je peux avoir par les
médias donc je vois des victimes est
effectivement parlé tout à l'heure
il ya beaucoup de victimes assez peu de
gens qui ont réchappé donc on voit
beaucoup les des victimes
donc j'ai tendance à surestimer
largement sachant qu'il ya 3000 par
exemple
moore incidents de la route dont
j'aurais plutôt intérêt à avoir peur
quand j'ai eu ma voiture mais j'ai pas
vraiment peur parce que c'est quelque
chose que je connais qui familier qui
est contrôlable sur lequel je peux agir
alors que le conte à virus à un risque
inconnu stockage une banque d'algérie
lors d'actions de la route c'est juste
pour la france les 3 millions d'euros du
corps navires us uniquement des nouveaux
niveaux et par ailleurs une autre
dimension importante ses dimensions plus
psychosocial le fait qu'au départ ça
touche une population éloignée donc les
chinois donc pour le diable qui as est
circonscrite dans d'antan et d'autant
que le la contagion c'est quand même une
question de distance sociale la
contagion s'est effectivement c'est
réguler la d'histoire de la distance
sociale et sociale soit la distance
physique entre devrait savoir entre 2,7
différents selon les pays et les
cultures tout à fait dire on pense même
qu à même d'aider des théoriciens qui
nous disent que les pays où il ya les
plus grandes distances sociales sur par
exemple en inde où il ya des
intouchables des gens que je ne peux
même pas touché eh bien ce sont des pays
qui ont été exposés à des pandémies
donc il ya encore des traces dans dans
la culture de deux pandémies par les
plus grandes distances sociales et c'est
pour cela sans réaction pandémie qui
l'ont connu qu ils ont instauré des
hypothèses d'évolution des 110 n'en ai
pas peur mais voilà antoinette rychner
vous êtes suisse vous êtes romancière et
drame et dramaturge votre nouveau roman
après le monde vient de paraître chez
buchet chastel or c'est un roman post
apocalyptique échos féministe et a
inspiré des thèses des collègues slug
pablos erwin d'ailleurs on dit beaucoup
de bien
lui aussi insistent sur l'entr'aide qui
doit avoir lieu après une catastrophe
tout comme vous c'est votre cas aussi
dans ce roman alors qu'est ce que cette
épidémie de coronavirus à de moderne à
vos yeux
alors le propre des théories de
l'effondrement c'est de mettre en
évidence la vulnérabilité nos sociétés
au regard économiques logistiques de
notre dépendance au pétrole de
dépendance au crédit est aussi la
mondialisation des circuits de
production de consommation note il a été
question donc dans cette optique
évidemment qu'on peut voir un virus mais
je dirai au même titre que une éruption
volcanique une grande panne généralisée
d'électricité ou un piratage ou un
problème dans l'esprit financière on
peut le voir comme un déclencheur de ce
qu'on appelle l'effet domino pour moi en
toc romancière finalement c'est pas
tellement coronavirus en tant que tel
qui va m'intéresser c'est plus ce qui
révèle justement des fragilités d'une
société qui en temps ordinaire se croit
toute puissante mais alors justement on
va commencer là dessus puisque les les
les mesures que l'on préconise
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas s'embrasser
de ne pas se serrer la main ne pas se
rassembler c'est le contraire de l'en
traite justement en cas de panne
d'énergie
l'entraînent ce serait fondamental dans
une danse une catastrophe dans un
effondrement à une théorie de
l'effondrement mais là tout à coup on
est dans un virus c'est à dire en gros
c'est tout ce qui a donné les films de
zombies et dans les films de zombies
l'entraînent c'est difficile près ce que
l'autre c'est à zombieland
en tout cas ça pourrait le devenir ou ça
l'est peut-être déjà ne s'est pas encore
là on est peut-être dans un cas ou
l'entr'aide c'est pas bon vous y avez
pensé
oui alors devant ma fiction il ya des
cas d'épidémies
parce que c'est une fiction longue qui
dure sur plusieurs décennies donc il ya
des moments aussi de quarantaine des
scènes aussi de violences de personnes
qui sont exclues parce qu'ils sont
malades et qu on les craint après je
pense que tout ça il faut pas oublier
que c'est un prétexte fictionnel pour
arriver le plus vite possible parce que
ce scénario de l'éruption de la
catastrophe soudaine et irréversible qui
est au début de ma fiction et pas à la
fin permet surtout d'arriver très
rapidement une forme de table rase qui
va me permettre ensuite de montrer une
reconstruction d'un monde différent du
nôtre et c'est après tout quand même ça
qui m'intéressait alors c'est des années
c'est vrai qu'on a vu beaucoup de films
catastrophes des films de fin du monde
celle avantages des effets numériques
ont fait beaucoup de progrès ces
derniers temps donc on peut visualiser
la fin du monde
une épidémie comme celle-là elle
s'inscrit dans ce cadre là forcément
quand on est médecin quand un
psychologue
on est obligé d'y penser on pense tous à
la fin du monde possible à les virus en
alu dans plein de films je comptais me
finalement c'est la contagion le film de
soderbergh garde à vue à l'écran il ya
un tour du monde à la personne ne
l'avait vu à l'époque ça ne sera pas ce
virus-là qui sera la cause de
l'effondrement de l'humanité mais il
pourra avoir un petit impact non je
voulais revenir un tout petit peu sur
l'entr'aide avec un petit bémol puisque
le fait de porter un masque en fait
quand on est malade c'est pour protéger
les autres donc dans ce sens là on a une
action alors de se faire vacciner
d'ailleurs et le fait de se faire faire
exactement et venir le fait de se faire
vacciner par exemple contre la grippe et
surtout pour les personnels soignants
c'est un acte altruiste pour aider les
autres c'est plus que pour s'aider
soi-même également
enfin la mobilisation que je peux voir
au quotidien à l'hôpital est partout
pour dépister le maximum de personnes
pour voir les isoler les prendre en
charge
montre que l'élan est là les landes
d'entraidé milla il existe un
même dans ce monde peut-être
d'individualistes et d'égoïste c'est
peut-être un cliché après tout sur
l'entr'aide mais on sait que la morale
par exemple c'est lié à la cause est une
façon de régler prennent la coopération
or le virus change de façon de de
coopérer que soit justement pour aider
dans le sens où je vais essayer de
soutenir ceux qui sont victimes ou les
dévaloriser pas parfois mais par
ailleurs aussi m'éloigner mais loin des
autos qui est possible que ce virus
change aussi notre logiciel moral plus
au delà de simplement de la simple
protection des maladies qui n'est pas
rien puisque c'est un besoin échapper
aux maladies ou protéger les siens c'est
un besoin humain fondamental
donc il ya ce mélange à la fois de
fondamental c'est à dire vraiment c'est
un besoin fondamental qu'on problème
penser qu'il est très programmée
on dit toujours a touché quelque chose
qui est plus lent ou qui est sensible ou
voilà et en même temps de dix paires
médiatique donc on est effectivement
cette connexion entre l'hyper médiatique
et le les choses fondamentales voilà les
les humeurs famille de dieu pendant très
longtemps on a associé l'idée la
progression des échanges économiques
amenant à de plus en plus de richesses
c'est un peu l'histoire du capitalisme à
travers les siècles que vous pensez que
ça pourrait être l'objet d'un
retournement aujourd'hui tout à cause
diable vous voyez les échanges
économiques voilà ce que ça donne à la
transmettre des virus
il faut bien avouer que depuis lehman
brothers depuis la crise financière on
nous fait à chaque fois le coup et et il
m'est arrivé d'y croire c'est à dire de
10 à 7 coups si ça va être différent
lehman brothers c'est fini là il ya le
g7 et le g20
on a considéré qu'il fallait réguler la
finance et donc on allait apprendre
ensuite crise souveraineté des crises
souveraines européennes ont dit à 100
c'est le début de l'europe sociale
ce coup ci le libéralisme et cetera le
chat le
la compétition le dumping social et
fiscal on a compris les irlandais on va
ça se passe pas troisièmement le fameux
retour des états ça y est c'est le
retour des états les entreprises elle
considère quand même les multinationales
qu'à son talent et un petit peu loin et
là elle se retrouve atteindre la sibylle
aux états qui leur viennent en aide
il va y avoir une sorte de répartition
non mais heureusement ou malheureusement
la démondialisation annoncé via la
finance via le budget via le retour de
l'état n'a pas eu lieu mais là on n'a
rien vu on nous annonce la
démondialisation gras chocolats grassois
cause l'acteur est ce que ce coup-ci
d'allofinance à a pas marché en
politique ça n'a pas marché
budgétairement ça n'a pas marché
est-ce que la salle on remarque même le
ministre de l'économie judo le maire a
évoqué oui il l'a dit en anglais
d'ailleurs ce qui est assez assez
paradoxal alors qu'il a évoqué bon la
question c'est de savoir au fond est-ce
qu'il va y avoir un rire les politiques
pour dire on peut relocaliser qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire alors déjà un économie
vous regardez comment ça se passe au
niveau des chaînes de valeur c'est être
con à fragmenter le processus de
production entre différents pays de
sorte que vous avez la chine qui paie
qui est incontournable et qui pèse entre
15 et 20% des chaînes de valeur de
fabrique à celle usine du monde en fait
on ne peut pas très facilement
je dirais se passer comme ça d'un coup
de baguette magique de la chine en
revanche on peut se dire c'est une
question de souveraineté on peut
relocaliser on peut lire il ya des
choses qu'on pourrait relocaliser pour
des questions effectivement d'emplois et
pour des questions aussi d'autonomie
d'autonomie alimentaire d'autonomie
technologique de souveraineté ou de
santé et de santé également à partir du
moment où c'est l'arrivée de santé mais
parce que quelque part oui à chaque fois
qu'on est dans une période de crise est
là monsieur que pourrait compléter ce
que je veux dire c'est que à partir -
rené sonné à un pic de crise il y à un
élément qui légitime l'intervention de
l'état
rappelez-vous la phrase de
de françois hollande qui dit il y a le
pacte de stabilité au lendemain des
attentats
mais il ya plus important que ça il ya
le pacte de sécurité
et là il dit les 3 % c'est bien gentil
mais on verra plus tard et il a raison
et tout le monde y compris les plus
libéraux au fond c'est légitime
effectivement il ya quelque chose au
dessus alors là on pourrait dire il ya
le pack sanitaires c'est au-dessus
encore alors là c'est quand même une
question de survie
et on se serait parfaitement légitime la
question c'est de savoir jusqu'où est ce
qu'on est dans une sorte de déclaration
d'intention qui parce que moi je
soutiens largement ou alors est-ce qu'il
ya je dirais des puissances économiques
financières qui pourront dire d'attendre
et non en fait on va essayer de
continuer comme avant malgré les
injonctions des politiques malgré les
injonctions des populations on arrive à
avoir une sphère économique et surtout
financière qui s'est autonomisée et qui
finit par je dirais jouer ses propres
règles qui tu as peu à ce qu' il ya une
prochaine crise
alors on l'a dit c'est ce virus est
assez contagieux il se répand assez vite
mais il est beaucoup moins grave qu'on
ne le croyait et tu peux on va dire
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle mais on
a l'impression qu'on sert aujourd'hui
l'hôpital pour faire de l' isolement de
malades qui par ailleurs ne sont pas mal
portants en fait ils ont le virus mais
je la pression que à la pitié certes
dans votre service c'est comme ça il ya
des gens bien portants qu'on isole vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est un virus
assez contagieux puisque une personne en
contrat en contamine entre 2 et 3 donc
plus contagieuse que la grippe qui tue
moins qu'on le pensait puisqu'au début
on ne recensait que les cas les plus
sévères en chine et donc on avait des
taux de mortalité élevé et maintenant
qu'on commence à dépister des gens de
moins en moins symptomatiques voir des
gens qui n'ont quasiment aucun symptôme
mais qu'on a des pistes et parce qu'ils
sont le père la mère le fils la femme
d'un des cas hospitalisés
on se rend compte que finalement il ya
beaucoup plus de porter compenser et de
ce fait la mortalité diminue et pour
arriver peut-être maintenant vers les 1
% c'est quand même au dessus aussi delà
de la mortalité de la grille néanmoins
vous avez raison nous nous retrouvons
nous soignant à l'hôpital dans une
situation un petit peu incongru où nous
nous occupons plus tellement de malades
mais deux personnes qu'il faut isoler et
c'est aussi ce qui nous est demandé
du reste de la population pour essayer
encore d'enrayer ce qui peut l'être
on sait que on n'échappera pas
l'épidémie en france mais gros peu le
retarder on essaie de la retarder en
dépistant un maximum de personnes et en
isolant les positif bien entendu on est
à la limite de notre système
vous le savez l'hôpital public déjà
aller mal avant on était déjà en
sous-effectif tous un petit peu fatigué
donc ça vient rajouter tout est dans
l'urgence on s'adapte bien évidemment où
on prend en charge les personnes on se
retrouva à dépister des dizaines et
bientôt des centaines de personnes on
reçoit plus de 1000 appels par jour je
la portais des masses des scaphandres
comme les chinois on voit les photos on
voit des tous les médecins avec des
scaphandres dans les scaphandres 6 qui
fout la trouille aussi des scaphandres
c'est plutôt en laboratoire quand on
manipule directement le virus nous nous
avons évidemment des
des tenues à gif sur blues avec des
masques ffp2 des lunettes des gants des
charlottes des surchaussures mais encore
une fois c'est pour éviter de disséminer
donc voilà on se retrouve là dans mon
service par exemple avec une vingtaine
de personnes en isolement donc ils sont
pas ils sont pas spécialement malade en
tout cas elles n'ont pas de critères
d'hospitalisation mais pour essayer de
retarder la transmission
il n'y a pas dans le personnel de
soignants qui déjà vous manquer de
personnel
il n'y a pas de cas déjà de gens
infectés qu'il faut retirer les cas dans
d'autres hôpitaux c'est le risque c'est
lorsqu'on a pris en charge une personne
sans savoir qu'elles étaient contaminés
et quand on l'apprend de trois jours
après ben on rappelle toutes les
personnes qui ont été amenées à s'en
occuper effectivement dans ces cas là
des personnels on est identifié à la
pitié aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas à ce
que je sache
mais parce que nous nous avons pris les
mesures dès l'arrivée des cas suspects
donc
et est-ce qu'on meure duclona virus est
ce qu'on meure d'autres balles a dit
qu'on avait et parce qu'on est rappelé
coronavirus tout à coup c'est balèze il
emporte
alors il semble effectivement que des
personnes qui en meurent sont les
personnes les plus fragiles donc il ya
un gradient avec l'âge plus on est âgé
plus on risque d'en mourir à plus de 50
en à une mortalité plus élevé qu'à plus
de 60 ans et à + 80 encore plus élevé
les enfants et inversement les enfants
ne présenterait pas de formes sévères et
puis en plus de l'âge et à d'autres
facteurs l'obésité le diabète toujours
les mêmes le tabagisme
et puis toutes les causes
d'immunodépression donc c'est un petit
peu toujours pareil l'espèce de
sélection naturelle et ce sont les plus
faibles qui succomberont tu es meilleur
oui ces masses que là ce sont
impressionnant puisqu'il déshumanise ont
donc intérêt à faire une situation
d'aidé humaine déshumanisant don qui est
ce qu'elle est même susceptible de
provoquer donc des visions très
émotionnel très émotionnel et on sait
que quand je suis avec monsieur n'est je
le transmets aux autres donc de créer
une sorte d'anxiété lors d'une recherche
très connus où on présente des serpents
exemple à des gens ils ont peur
évidemment
l'anxiété est ensuite apprendre des
fleurs ils ont peur des fleurs qui ne
sont pas familières et donc le danger
c'est l'idée que lorsqu'on a une peur
quelques patates ans à se diffuser vers
dans d'autres secteurs et donc je peux
avoir peur des fleurs un peu bizarre si
à part le moment où je suis moi même en
état en état de peur et de fait ce qu'il
y à partir de ce moment là je suis donc
cette cette anxiété fait que tout ce que
de ce que je vais interpréter va être
traitée sous un angle émotionnel et plus
ou alors rationnelle d'ailleurs c'est le
cas régence à la sauterie du complot on
a dit que c'est rome qui a effectivement
volontairement mis en place en chine ce
ce virus pour contrer la puissance
économique chinoise
donc effectivement ça peut me rassure et
ça donne quelque chose qui est
contrôlable un système justification
d'explication et voilà donc je sais
pourquoi le virus est là et quand on
voit des gens avec les masques les plus
classiques un concept habitué à voir en
occident depuis l'épidémie de strass
d'ailleurs un en 2003 on a vu tout à
coup des avions venant d'asie avec des
gens qui sortaient avec ce masque qu'on
connaissait peu encore à l'époque
est ce que c'est un facteur inquiétant
rassurant parce que après tout s'il
porte un masque c'est pour nous protéger
vous nous l'avez dit mais en face il
porte un masque c'est qu'ils ont été en
contact avec ou à proximité de gens qui
à risque et puis en plus on nous dit que
finalement ce match qui ne sert pas à
grand-chose fois qu'il aurait une
autonomie de 3 heures
c'est vrai il sert pendant trois heures
ou blogueurs trois heures on peut le
jeter il doit être porté par les malades
pour éviter qu'ils ne transmettent à via
les gouttelettes voilà mais ça n'évite
pas la contamination manu portet et
effectivement il a une durée de vie
entre voilà trois quatre heures qui fait
qu'il faudrait le changer régulièrement
puisque bout d'un moment il perd son
caractère de filtre est effectivement
pour les personnes non malades il n'a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt en tant que tel
franck dedieu qui le facteur plus
important si la familiarité donc c'est
pas le fait qu'ils aient un masque y en
ait pas c'est que je sois familier sûr
qu'en france la solution du masque est
récente et donc effectivement elle peut
que ça peut paraître peu nation
m'appartient moment où ça commence à se
diffuser c'est la familiarité quel
principe à huy en belgique et trois ils
ont tous le sourire que effectivement là
ce que vous dites c'est que il ya une
forme d'irrationalité qui finit tout de
même dans l'humanité parce rationaliser
par se rétablir
le problème par exemple avec les marchés
financiers la notion de
d'autoréalisation c'est qu'en soit le
réel ne les intéresse plus c'est à dire
que la peur du réel et la peur du
changement ce passage des fleurs non
familière plutôt des serpents ou fleurs
d'un familière sacré déjà quelque chose
réellement à dire qu'à partir du moment
où on se dit il y a ce ce dont j'ai peur
au nom de la gestion du risque et au nom
du fait qu'on fait tous à peu près la
même chose
eh bien il faut que je réagisse en
premier et donc il ya un phénomène de
panique qui n'est pas forcément qu'il ne
s'en sert pas forcément dans une logique
de réalité mais qui finit par être auto
réalisant et qui pour lui en revanche
des effets bien réel et réalise que vous
ne tentant de dire c'est que les marchés
financiers
je suis métaphore du coronavirus où le
corps d'un virus est une métaphore des
marchés fait je vous dire c'est
peut-être les deux et ça va être dans la
catastrophe filmée par exemple la sur
les marchés il ya une question qui se
pose est difficile d'y répondre
c'est qu'habituellement m'ont dit vous
savez dans ces cas là l'or devrait
monter l heure ne mentent pas et ils les
mêmes depuis une semaine en baisse alors
vous ça vous nous aviez choque pas que
leur
baysse un petit peu alors chiche cornol
sa corne manawi mais dans l'univers des
marchés cette question là ça c'est
nouveau
quelque part c'est le passage aux fleurs
qu'on ne connaît pas ça c'est nouveau
mon dieu si même la valeur refuge est
une espèce de deux voiliers de cette
sûreté du dehors
voilà ducasse andré finit aussi par nous
échapper là quelque part l'heure est
grave qu'est ce qu'on va faire
eh bien on va se poser la question
pendant la pause mais on se retrouve
juste après pour continuer ce débat
[Musique]
nous continuons notre débat sur le corps
anna virus épidémies modernes typique du
21e siècle avec élise clément frutos qui
est infectiologues la pitié salpêtrière
avec franck dedieu le directeur adjoint
de la rédaction de marianne
il est spécialisé en économie avec
thierry meyer professeur de psychologie
à l'université paris-x nanterre
il travaille sur la perception des
risques et antoinette rychner qui est
suisse romancière et dramaturge et dont
le nouveau roman après le monde vient de
paraître chez buchet chastel
c'est un roman sur l'effondrement alors
antoinette vous lire rebondir
oui est dans une fiction d'effondrement
il ya bien sûr l'idée que tout à coup la
finitude devient s'impose notre notre
condition de finitude s'impose je pense
que dans nos sociétés actuelles on n'est
pas du tout familier justement de cette
idée que la maladie puisse tuer thierry
meyer l'a bien dit on a beaucoup plus il
ya beaucoup plus de morts par la route
par exemple que par la maladie en tout
cas dans d'autres idées parce que dans
les chiffres se sont pas tout à fait
vrai mais pourtant dans notre histoire
il ya eu des épidémies 1300 présente la
teste et je pense qu'on continue de le
porter en nous mais comment on peut
réactiver sa comment accepter aussi
parce que finalement d'un point de vue
numérique trois morts en quatre mois
maintenant en france
qu'est-ce que ça déclenche chez nous et
comment on pourrait aussi se donner les
moyens peut-être symbolique culturelle
d'être plus serein avec cette idée de la
mort on a on est aussi avec l'idée des
progrès de la médecine qui ont été
absolument fabuleux au cours de deux des
dernières décennies au cours du dernier
siècle en particulier et on se dit bien
là comme par exemple quand on est au
stade 2 monde essaye de retarder le
virus on se dit que bah c'est pour
trouver une riposte à dire un vaccin et
on se dit tous d'ailleurs qu'on va
trouver un vaccin je parlais du film de
steven soderbergh que beaucoup de gens
ont regardé depuis quelques semaines
depuis le début de l'épidémie de
coronavirus c'est l'épidémie du neuf
violence d'une brutalité d'une mortalité
infiniment supérieur à ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
mais on attend record il trouvait à 20
avec ça dans le film ces avantages des
films c'est tout va très vite
et là c'est pareil on se dit on va
trouver un match de toute façon ça va
être réglée assez vite d'ailleurs il
faut noter qu'un virus qui tue
rapidement et de manière très importante
ne se vit survivra pas très longtemps et
raccourcir à sa propre épidémie ah oui
donc le film de soderbergh il est
réaliste dans ce sens là un virus comme
celui du sart scob ne donc le quorum n'a
virus dont on parle ce soir il est
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire qu'ils tuent
mais pas trop il se transmet bien et
donc il ya des chances de durer
peut-être même de devenir endémique
alors les wagons des bic c'est à dire de
perdurer à petit à la petite échelle on
continue avec bien sûr des pics
saisonniers comme pour tous ces virus
d'accord concernant les vaccins c'est
pas si facile
vous le savez dans d'autres virus comme
la le vih la dague on est toujours à la
recherche de vaccins à la fois efficace
et non plus dangereux pour ceux qui sont
vaccinées que ceux qui ne le sont pas
pour le coran navires us voilà les
experts les experts estiment qu'on aura
absolument rien d'efficace avant au
moins juillet 2021 donc d'ici là cette
bouffée épidémique actuel sera sera
largement passé alors parmi les mesures
auxquelles on assiste en france
aujourd'hui on a vu qu'on on a lu lé
s'attendent de salons professionnels on
a ride raccourci le salon de
l'agriculture on a on annule le salon de
l'immobilier à cannes on annule le salon
du livre à paris mais en revanche les
grands musées reste ouvert
le louvre reste ouvert enfin tout sauf
quand les les employés décident eux
mêmes de se mettre en retrait mais on
trouve logique de laisser ouvert des
très grands musées qui attire énormément
de touristes comme le comme le louvre et
de fermer le salon du livre à paris vous
l'expliquer d'une certaine manière dans
un bâtiment universités qui a douze
mille personnes dont des années 60 et je
le dis toujours aux étudiants vous avez
plus de chances d'attraper le rhume que
donc en un virus et il se pose la
question mais il n'y a pas d'eau chaude
chez dans ce bâtiment encore en est donc
arrivé à l'université il ya aucun
problème puisque le conte se lave les
mains de l'eau chaude n'a aucun impact
sur le sait tous c'est d'avoir du savon
pendant plus de vingt secondes qui va
fait qu affaire qui va faire un effet
donc effectivement il ya des différences
d'échelle assez considérés de la même
manière le préfet de l'oise a fermé les
marchés en plein air mais il laisse
ouvert les grandes surfaces et les
hypermarchés oublie que après tout le
petit détaillant le petit maraîcher à
une force de
d'une capacité de se plaindre bien
moindre que un hypermarché par exemple
que ce sont je le ferme et l'autre pas
si on regarde la communication
gouvernementale je trouve qu'elle est
relativement bien maîtrisé puisqu'il est
important la communication de que des
experts soient crédibles donc là je
pense qu'ils laissent la place comme
aide à diageo zéralda santé les des
instructions pour que nous chaque jeu
directeur des communications du bit est
le chef de service ne parle pas
directement au public mais la formation
soit transmise est gérée à l'échelle
collective les consignes sont
relativement claires il ya eu des
progrès du côté de la maison en plein
air on a moins de risque sont amis n'est
que dans un milieu confiné absolument
aberrant c'est de fermer les marchés
avaient alors qu'on sait très bien que
ça va vraiment posé des problèmes à des
petits détaillants bien sûr alors cela
dit si c'est grave il faut le faire mais
quand même
mais quand même maman on laisse ouvert
les grandes surfaces ça paraît dingue
est ce que le y aurait pas une logique
économique la data coup franc de la même
manière on pourra dire pourquoi adultes
ont le barathon effet de faire me trompe
pas disney le regard je suis parti d'un
a priori de de confiance quand même et
de compétences des gens qui désirent
effectivement on me disait les
supermarchés peuvent continuer à
fonctionner et puis en revanche pas des
manifestations entendre quelqu'un de
votre compétence votre niveau 10 c'est
aberrant
là ça me va pas parce que je me suis dit
il doit y avoir une réponse serait pas
forcément eux ils savent bon et c'est
quelque part je pense que ça suppose
quand même la confiance le fait que le
gouvernement délègue la gestion à une
logique assez les intérêts économiques
trump c'est comme dans les dents de la
mer ils se faisaient dans les eaux de la
mer la lutte si elle est le maire de la
ville veut pas faire mais voilà les
veut pas dire qu'il ya un requin qui tue
les gens parce qu'il attend le lathan
des touristes pour le week end du 4
juillet on en vient à bélouve on en
vient forcément en déduire cela quand on
entend un spécialiste dire c'est
aberrant effectivement on se dit il ya
deux poids deux mesures qui lié à
l'importance et à la puissance
économique et financière des acteurs
maintenant à ce jeu là on peut aussi
s'en mordre les doigts parce que si ça
va contre la transition vers une
autonomie l'autonomie dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure puisque des détails on au
marché ce serait plus des producteurs
locaux que les suisses qui ce qui va
approvisionner les supermarchés
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
politiquement pour obtenir cette
autonomie politiquement je pense que le
gouvernement a décidé de déléguer
quelque part presque la communication au
jour le jour à des spécialistes pour se
donner une certaine manière on a c'est
un peu l'antithèse de lusine de rouen
lubrizol
quelque part on se disait le ministre et
il a été sur le devant de la scène
ils ont été prompts 4 à se mobiliser
quelques heures après l'explosion et
c'est là on a l'impression qu'au
contraire on va dire on va donner la
parole à la délègue à des experts il
savait pourquoi puisque dans le cadre du
brésil ça n'a pas empêché les complots
les théories du complot de prospérer et
effectivement vous avez un lieu quelque
part je verrai une sorte de tragédie
avec une unité de temps et de lieu là
c'est beaucoup plus diffus donc
effectivement on a l'impression que le
le le
on se dit que le politique et à
l'obligation de transmettre le bébé la
patate chaude si j'ose dire aux
[Musique]
compétences sanitaire dans le cas du
préfet de l'oise pour justifier la
fermeture
enfin fait de le laisser ouvert les
grosses de chauffage et les disques
parce que les gens circulent dans les
grandes surfaces ne stagne pas ma part
aux quatre j'imagine montpellier
peut-être pas pensé
si tout le monde respecter les mesures
annoncées c'est à dire quand on est
malade on reste chez soi
effectivement il y aurait quand même
et les gens le font quand même
globalement des gens le font de même que
les gens moi je suis toujours surpris de
voir des gens qui acceptent d'être
hospitalisée quinze jours dans une
petite pièce à pression négative
ça c'est les gens qui s'y connaît le
combiné comme jamais comment alors
expliquer ce que c'est que les pièces à
pression négative c'est à dire que c'est
les pièces où on peut pas ouvrir les
fenêtres
c'est ça alors ouvrir les fenêtres c'est
un moyen aussi de faire alors que chez
toi en priorité il vaudrait mieux ouvrir
la fenêtre 90e on peut ouvrir les
fenêtres
ah bon mais le fait d'avoir ces fameuses
pression négative et vite que quand on
ouvre les portes par contre les
gouttelettes et des particules virales
puisse si à l'extérieur de la chambre
donc la save reste amateur de la chanson
my est un système des wagons
voilà mais il n'y a pas assez de chambre
à pression négative dans les hôpitaux
pour accueillir tous les malades
aujourd'hui
donc ils sont également d'entendre
secondes mais enfin les voilà les gens
acceptent de rester confinés et c'est
très difficile à vivre et le font encore
une vue mais vous sous la houlette du
gouvernement
est-ce que ça a un sens à la fois de de
fermer des endroits et en même temps de
laisser
le métro le train et l'avion
fonctionnaient est ce que tout cela a un
sens il faut bien faire quelque chose
faut bien interdire quelque chose quoi
c'est la mode
je ne sais pas comment calculer l'impôt
rationnel on peut dire sur le marché les
gens c'est un lieu de conversation de
sociabilité où on se parle de retraite
non mais oh je chante entre acheter sur
mécanismes de protection g de vendredi
je protège la crédibilité de du message
on est tous tendance à faire ça on a
l'impression qu'il faut forcément
prendre une décision interdire quelque
chose sinon n'est pas crédible sinon on
a on peut laisser l'impression qu'on ne
fait pas son travail alors que d'après
ce que vous dites on pense que c'est pas
tellement lac se passe le travail au
fond c'est une responsabilité de chacun
si on se sent pas bien à l'école pas
sortir et sari sais c'est pas en
interdisant le marathon est pas
disneyland qu'on va changer quoi la joie
que je crois que les gens sont quand
même capable de c'est là où l entraide
c'est là où la responsabilité de chacun
c'est vrai quand vous dites je ne sais
pas quelque part on peut pas supporter
venant de spécialistes elle sera là on
ne peut pas à supporter mettez vous à la
place d'un ministre
je ne sais pas non vous pouvez pas faire
profession de votre ignorance et pas
possible vous devez et dans quelque part
belle ministre il doit décider et y at
il une part d'arbitraire
moi j'avais l'impression que non mais
maintenant j'apprends que oui c'est vrai
que c'est assez embêtant on ne peut pas
supporter cette phrase je ne sais pas et
je crois qu'il faut c'est si les médias
c'est un spécialiste de la prévention
des risques
et puis surtout de la prévention alors
avec toutes les agences de santé vous
avez travaillé avec elle là en
l'occurrence c'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
car dd déjà j'en parlais au début il ya
des différences ça ça illustre l'effort
de comptes de deux systèmes de contrôle
social c'est ce qui se passe en chine et
systèmes autoritaires chinois n'est pas
du tout le mode de régulation ou de
conches loisy si vous êtes libres
d'aller de l'habitat du bon voilà donc
paradoxalement ce a renversé son compte
et des pays qui ont moins un système
sanitaire beaucoup plus fragile que le
col que le no dans qu'est la
vulnérabilité peu de la perception de
viralité va peut être vraiment
avérait du fait que les gens ne seront
pas protégés la seconde est plutôt
tranquille avec ça parce qu'on sait qu'à
côté on a un système de protection
sociale or social déjà ce qui n'est pas
le cas aux états unis parce que beaucoup
servi et beaucoup de beaucoup de 10
millions de personnes qui n'ont pas de
protection sociale et donc qu'il a
craint du grenat virus change de le
totalement du fait qu'ils c'est la
crainte de ne pas avoir les moyens de se
protéger
en france on a quand même c'est le
protection cette protection sociale qui
nous permet d'être plus serein dire à la
fois le risque qu'on semblait même si on
sait qu'on est l'émotion entend
s'adapter ce qui est spécifique d'une
émotion se condense à la partager dès
que je suis jean émotions on a parlé
tous du camp même du centre nous ça
c'est un mécanisme très connu ce fait le
partage social d'émotion je leur
souhaite g d'émotion gens parlent à
d'autres et donc ça a tendance à
amplifier et du fait qu'on est protégé
finalement en france voilà on arrive à
réguler dans d'autres pays fait
attention si les choix de crise est
internationale on peut avoir des
réactions très tout à fait différente
d'abord principe en afrique il ya pas du
tout protection ou peut avoir des
phénomènes aussi de jeu par les dates et
regroupant dallas on n'a pas beaucoup
parlé des le fait que deux que ça touche
aussi des groupes sociaux les chinois
qui peuvent lier à la fin soit
l'apparence physique ou à la voix ou là
on atteint il ya précemment il ya eu d
une interdiction de la scission des
banques d'un sur un paquebot par exemple
on est mal vue sur donc on allait très
agréable à voir les restes d un pas
qu'on parlait catastrophisme et de des
impacts en termes d' agression entre
groupe du fait que l'armée y est réel ou
avérées ou pas certains groupes peuvent
être conservées comme nation donc s'il
ya quand même un danger en france sept
protos et protection sociale nous
protège de beaucoup de choses il ya
quand même quand dans le métro on a vu
des gens se s'éloigner ou se protéger
quand il y avait 70 des touristes
chinois et italiens ce qui est difficile
c'est plus difficile
et même s'il n'était pas par ailleurs ni
chinois ni touristes
évidemment
juste vous parliez d'afrique est ce que
dans un pays où on peut mourir de faim
est-ce que la crainte d'un virus
intermédiaires comme deux corps un virus
c'est peut-être pas secondaire je me
demande si on n'est pas aussi dans une
parano de pays riches quoi avec eux nos
besoins nos besoins essentiels qui sont
satisfaits donc une menace qui qui a
comme relative la gère tout à coup nous
nous fait paniquer c'est nouveau et on
ne sait pas encore comment le prendre en
charge on n'a pas encore les traitements
efficaces n'a pas encore les vaccins
donc on est démuni
donc c'est ça qui nous met une autre
voilà notre vulnérabilité qui fait peur
la vulnérabilité vous l'avez dit elle
est également économique alors le risque
de il ya un risque de crise industrielle
puisqu'on l'a dit la chine celle usine
du monde donc il ya les allemands pour
fabriquer leurs machines outils qu'ils
exportent ensuite à travers le monde et
notamment en chine ils ont besoin de la
chine pour vous c'est à dire que c'est
devenu je dirais pas la chine n'est pas
devenu une sorte d' opportunités comme
quelque part dans l'est au début des
années 2000 c'est une opportunité
volkswagen dit tiens on va pouvoir
vendre plus mature et c'est là c'est
plus ça c'est à dire que c'est devenu un
élément essentiel du système productif
et des stratégies et connaître de la
chaîne de montage
grosso modo de chacun des pays c'est à
dire que vous avez le tout tout l'
architecture le processus productif
français est fondé sur l'idée qu'on va
importer des produits venant de chine
qu'on pourra proposer aux consommateurs
à moindre coût mais en revanche
eh bien on bridera l'augmentation des
salaires
enfin ça c'est le 31 prestations mais de
survivre avec eux d'un taux de chômage
élevé donc quelque part les les
allemands ont se sont dit non on va
faire une politique très mercantiliste
on va pouvoir vendre exporter nos
voitures et
on va quand même pour avoir un coût
relativement on va en revanche les
produire ici et non pas parce que
stratégie française aussi je n'ai pas
paria mais c'est plutôt de produire à
l'extérieur vous allez les productions à
l'intérieur qui sont ensuite réimporter
effectivement vous avez vous pourrez
importer entre guillemets compris il a
beau habiter des prix des pièces dont on
se sert ensuite pour fabriquer des
chouettes chez l'humain absolument donc
c'est vrai que ça c'est une stratégie
française qui diffère de l'associé de la
stratégie allemande qui est une
stratégie non pas de production sur le
pays mais de production en allemagne
pour pouvoir l'exporter c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela qu'ils se sont dit comme on
veut aller plus avant dans cette
stratégie mercantiliste de production
chez nous pour un but d'exportation et
bien on va essayer de tenir les salaires
allemands et donc quelque part la
demande intérieure allemande n'a pas été
très forte mais on a pu vivre avec ça
entre parenthèses cette demande
intérieure forte des allemands qui sait
je dirais qu'il s'est amenuisée par
l'absence de pouvoir d'achat parce qu'on
dit on pas poudre monte trop on fait des
lois de flexibilité du travail et bien
ce sont les français qui travaillaient
avec des événements qui exporter des
produits allemands qui ont pu je dirais
qu'elles n'ont souffert parce que les
allemands n'ont pas pu acheter faute de
demande intérieure suffisante
là il y aurait quelques produits
risquent de manquer bientôt parce que
justement il n'y a plus la chine pour
les fabriquer ou en tout cas l'iphone
l'iphone par vous allez 80% de la
production des métaux et sont essentiels
à la fabrication des matériaux
électrique c'est un rat qui sont je
dirais dans les mains de lachine vous
avez tord qu'on fabriquait enfin qu on
raffine est en france mais qu'on a
exporté là bas parce que ça pollue voilà
vous avez 53 pour cent de la production
mondiale d'acier alors vous allez dire
mais on n'a qu'à faire de l'acier on
ferme des usines chez nous on n'a qu'à
les airs et ouvrir sauf que
effectivement ça change radicalement le
processus de production dont je pense
que on peut être
imaginez peut-être à cette occasion la
repenser les choses en terme de
relocalisation
en plus de ça vous l'avez vous avez dit
non seulement il ya une dimension
sanitaire
il ya aussi une dimension écologique on
retrouvera celte eu peur un peu à la
fois de la fin du monde ça imaginez que
là tout ça soit réglé dans quatre mois
de la rapatrier chez nous la fabrication
d'acier mais c'était exactement ce que
je disais à mes débuts je t'ai rien
c'est exactement ce que je disais en
début d'émission c'est à dire
qu'effectivement à partir du moment où
on a résolu plus ou moins la crise de
l'immense brothers gros on arrive nous
lui plus ou moins la crise grecque est
bien effectivement on repart comme avant
parce que il ya je dirais une
problématique qui mettrait des années à
se repenser et puis une un problème
qu'on arrive à résoudre plus ou moins du
mois à mettre la poussière sous le tapis
au bout de quatre mois
donc effectivement c'est peut-être
reparti pour un tour on connaîtra tout
même les risques à court terme mais les
risques à moyen ou long terme
on sait bien qu'on n'a plus les réserves
en matières premières qu'elles sont en
train de s'épuiser les métaux rares
qu'il faut justement même pour les
technologies renouvelables une maison
basse consommation c'est bourré de
technologie pour avoir des capteurs
thermiques pour avoir les stores qui se
ferme selon la météo
tout ça ça consomme des métaux rares
kokkola de moins en moins une eco race
est extrêmement leur extraction c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont rares d'ailleurs ça
nécessite des dégâts énormément et j'ai
l'impression de toute façon un moment
donné les les transports qui sont
actuellement à très bas coût ces coups
là ils vont augmenter donc j'ai
l'impression que la question de la
relocalisation c'est une question de
délai peut-être que ce sera pas le
coronavirus qui va qui va faire changer
ça mais tôt ou tard on sait bien que
d'ici la moitié du siècle il faudra il
faudra prendre le problème à bras le
corps et des yeux que bon faut dire à
d'autres épidémies voilà ce n'est pas
celle là
je vous évoquez tout à l'heure la
l'accroissement de la population pour
nous les envoyer à la carte que tout à
l'heure la population mondiale mais
également et je voudrais revenir sur
cette carte que vous nous avez montré à
fonction de l'accroissement de la
population mondiale
on voit que les épidémies au fonds
servent de régulateur c'est ça alors
voilà il ya eu des oscillations voit un
petit peu en bas de la courbe si vous
montez la montre est là d'ailleurs ces
oscillations sont plutôt dues aux
changements aux clippers 0 période de
changement climatique des périodes sur
des périodes froides
si on prend la courbe de la france on
voit vraiment l'impact des grandes
épidémies voilà tel que la peste le
choléra et puis égal à chaque fois qu'il
ya des crocs également les guerres et ce
qui est intéressant il une carte sur
l'effondrement
voilà ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir dans la théorie
développé par le couple mid aux îles qui
se passe lorsqu'on atteint l'équilibré
c'est à dire que le milieu la charge de
la population à moment donné à un impact
tel que elle elle va à sa propre perte
alors l'idéal ce serait la coupe de
gauche c'est à dire que on se rend
compte que on n'a pas une limite de ce
qu'on peut exploiter et à ce moment là
on maîtrise notre propre population
ça c'est un coq de gauche 52 à la
chantre je sais quoi on a dépassé
malheureusement se sait pointillés c'est
un peu l'image de yves paccalet avec les
lapins dans la clairière fermé donc les
la passe se reproduise plus qu'à un
moment ils ont ils ont plus rien à
manger donc à trois solutions soit un
moment donné ils se disent bon on est
assez nombreux si on continue comme ça
on n'aura pas assez à manger donc en
charrette s'arrête c'est l'idéal ce que
quelque part la population humaine
n'aurait dû faire quand elle a atteint
c'est 100 premiers millions ou son
premier milliard la leur est dû se dire
ok bon maintenant on va peut-être
arrêter d'avoir plus d'un enfant au
maximum deux parcours on a continué et
si on continuait de manière
exponentielle ce serait la courbe de
droite arriverait à l'effondrement
fiscale moment on aurait pu les
ressources voilà s'il n'y a plus assez
de pétrole ne peuvent pas nourrir la
population
donc on arriverait à ça mais la courbe
du milieu ce sont les oscillations alors
une catastrophe naturelle l'une une
guerre une épidémie il y en aura
d'autres et des beaucoup plus grave que
celle là fatsah donnera donc une
diminution transitoire et partiel alors
on sait pas de quel niveau ça dépendra
des épidémies qui permettra de diminuer
un petit peu la pression sur
l'environnement et sur les ressources et
de nouveau la population revenus tra et
voilà c'est vers ça on a l'air de tomber
ce ne sera pas suffisant pour empêcher
voilà les dégâts déjà fait par
l'humanité sur d'autres planètes
lorsque le malthusianisme n'est pas née
dans la tête d'un pasteur n'est en fait
est totalement naturelle j'ajouterai
quand même pour
relativisez votre approche c'est que
finalement le seul pays qui a voulu
maîtriser sa démographie c'est quand
même la chine d'où vient paradoxe le
corona virus
donc il ya quand même c'est pas aussi
simple que ça la relation entre la
production de richesse potentielle le la
population via on peut aussi croire au
progrès et de se dire finalement nous
avons les moyens alors il ya des
géographes qui le disent
spécialiste de l'agriculture on a les
moyens de nourrir diviseur de l'humain
qu'aujourd'hui largement vrai moi je
suis pas un spécialiste de ces questions
là mais je crois que pour dire que
l'éruption d'un virus soit une sorte de
de déterminisme démographique pour faire
baisser par accident la population est
prorogé la survie de l'espèce et pas
dans ce sens là je voulais le dire je
voulais dire que les zones de forte
densité de population favorise la
dissémination des maladies et les
mobilise la mobilisation aussi des
populations quand les colons sont
arrivés en amérique ou en australie etc
ils ont amené avec leur maladie ça a
détruit que face à a tué probablement 80
% des gens qui étaient déjà là donc ça a
toujours existé et c'est voilà c'est si
nous on se met dans des situations de
surpopulation ou de deux paquebots où il
ya quatre mille personnes sur un bateau
ou de deux cars de touristes et je ne
sais quelle autre situation avec des
gens avec moins d'un mètre carré par
personne forcément moi je les ai vécus
avec les camps de réfugiés aussi avec
médecins sans frontières ont créé les
conditions de des épidémies j'ai eu à
gérer les épidémies de dengue de
typhoïde
donc voilà c'est ça que je voulais dire
on les accepte d'autant moi j'étais
assez au total 100 pour 2 juillet 2021
vous avez dit finalement on pourra pas
avoir un vaccin fin juillet d'un terme a
semblé très très
loin au greta l'échelle de l'humanité
par des mots pour automne attriste
heures parce que c'est l'arrivée dans
votre sujet à palmyre sur la
problématique alimentaire c'est à dire
qu'on l'entend beaucoup attention à
surpopulation n'arrivera pas nourrir
tout le monde a oublié que c'est pas une
question uniquement de production que
c'est une question de distribution
actuellement on a bien assez pour
nourrir toute la population mondiale
simplement ce qui se passe est la
nourriture elle va là où est l'argent
donc c'est encore une fois des
motivations économiques de profit qui
font que ça mal distribué ce que l'on
produit aussi c'est l'accaparement des
terres agricoles ce que l'on produit
aussi on reproduit de préférence pour
ceux qui ont les moyens de l'acheter
tout à fait et l'impact environnemental
il est beaucoup plus élevé pour les
populations industriel mais c'est à dire
questions et de reste juste une minute
devait écrire un roman sur
l'effondrement un roman collapse hologue
on va dire pour ce que vous avez tiré là
dedans en ce moment on sait qu'il ya
vraiment là où il ya du loup pour ça
aussi des maths dans la littérature
c'est celle opportune chinian temps mais
dieu vous aviez un vrai goût pour
l'effondrement est vraiment cet attrait
pour la table rase l'idée d'une
reconstruction politique
oui c'est ce que celle après la prennent
pas se cacher les collabos l'ogre il
faut savoir qu'il ya aussi des théories
en faveur d'un effondrement graduelle
lent alors bon pourquoi j'ai choisi un
effondrement brutal
évidemment parce que c'est plus
spectaculaire on va pas se mentir et le
plus grand de la croche émotionnel mais
aussi parce que c'était la voie la plus
rapide vers cette table rase qui
permettait d'imaginer un autre mode avec
plus d'autonomie on a dit puis je crois
que les téléspectateurs et
téléspectatrices qui est qu'ils nous
entendent
s'ils ont eu la chance de faire pousser
dans un jardin potager leurs propres
légumes ou fruits on sait bien que c'est
pas du tout la même satisfaction de
manger ça que d'acheter un anonyme et
même faire son propre pain c'est une
tout autre satisfaction donc pour moi
c'est ça qui fait rêver c'est quand même
un monde de beaucoup plus de simplicité
on pourrait rire maîtriser nos
productions re maîtrisez au moins des
équipements qu'on pourrait réparer nous
mêmes
après il ya eu toujours une
concentration de production spécialisés
ça c'est normal ça va ça va resté mais
quand on parle de la chine ont comparé
les technologies mais il ya des exemples
beaucoup plus bêtes par exemple 80% des
boutons à fermeture éclair du monde
de son produit d'une même ville qui au
tout en chine ça me paraît insensé merci
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]